[Music]
all right i have
a uh a nice touching love story here
that i feel like steve would probably do
for nikki so
this couple here or i would do for
george
that's true oh [ __ ] i unintentionally
shaded you again [ __ ] i'm so sorry
i think you do it on purpose no it was
so intentional
i saw that shade being thrown day today
i've seen it i saw the formulation
yeah like your eyes were literally
choosing everyone in the room in a way
locked on target no i promise
we'll see you know that's not true yeah
we'll see we'll see it's gonna be a long
day
i'm sorry i take it back so this this
story
bart would definitely do too late too
late pam should cut you up right out
real quick
national [ __ ] do no right i'll be the
judge of that
all right so joe would definitely do no
never
no so absolutely now you're just telling
lies yeah i know i am
now i have this shady girl in the public
wait what is going on
let me hear it first okay so the story
is this couple
so they've been married super in love
but the wife tragically passed in a car
accident three years ago
and so her definitely a steve story he
killed her and so her husband
he so for her her whole life she always
wanted like her dream home and all this
stuff right so the husband
put in a lot of money a lot of effort to
create this dream home of hers
and then he married another woman it was
like [ __ ] you can't have it no more
because i got it with this new chick
okay
oh no bart would definitely do that
that is a part story that wasn't me
throwing the shade
so so anyway so then what he ended up
doing was for the house warming
event he commissioned someone to
create a lifelike ultra realistic
statue of his wife made out of silicone
and he did this out of love don't tell
me he sounds creepy as [ __ ] though
yeah that's like you can't let go of her
yeah well out of silicone so it's
squishy yes exactly because usually
they're like
uh we can make it out of her water yeah
that's silicone yeah can you do the
silicone version so i can [ __ ] my wife
theater no so he actually wanted to do
it out of wax
he wanted a wax sculpture but then the
the artist
it's gonna melt that's exactly why so
because of the fact that they live in a
place that's really hot they were like
oh no this i think
silicone is probably better or the guy's
like you know you can't [ __ ] wax and
he's like oh [ __ ] okay yeah thanks
yeah that's stupid dude that'll be crazy
this is the story that is like it just
like took
india and they're just like oh that's so
sweet he loves her so
much it is sweet it's very sweet so they
they
he bought her dream house oh my god yeah
and then they had this like photo shoot
well they had like a whole housewarming
event
and so they had her displayed there oh
so she could see her
her her dream house oh how long ago did
she pass away three years ago three
years ago
if i was her i'd be so pissed i'd be
like [ __ ] how dare you
[ __ ] achieve and steal my dreams
without me well no it's not without her
because she's right there yeah
that's the i'm the spirit i'm like
that's not me
this is imposter the [ __ ] that is
insanely realistic
so you should see the i don't know i
didn't grab the video but there is a
video of them being
interviewed or whatever but on the side
view it's it's like i think it's
the daughter or someone is like tending
to the statue and like
fixing the dress and all these things so
she actually has like all her toes there
and like her hands and like you can see
her like moving the hands and like they
kind of like
move a little bit like silicon you know
what i mean it's like really life-like
it's so creepy this is never i could
never i could i think it would break my
heart more
yes i can't be reminded i can't be
reminded i would have to [ __ ]
completely detach
yeah absolutely what are you gonna do
when after this photo shoot is done
she's just gonna chill there collect
dust all day yeah she's
living there is she anatomically correct
yeah i was gonna say compared to like a
statue
if you if you make a statue with clothes
you just carve out their clothes
this one they had to carve out all the
genitals and everything and then put
clothes on so it looks right
yeah i mean unless they left it alone
then that also looks even weirder
where it's just like oh this white
silicone middle do you think they went
to a sex doll factory and got
it done so she's got everything i want
to think that
i don't think so i think it's probably
like a barbie doll
you think that was just smooth probably
like a barbie doll there's no vaginas
probably there's probably no point of
them putting like giving her toes if
she's wearing shoes but they did that
anyways
she's barefoot though oh yeah never mind
yeah that's how i was able to see that
she had toes
it's obviously a very sweet story but in
my mind it turns pretty bad
what is what's happening in your she's
trying to [ __ ] her all the time
i mean it's still kind of sweet yeah
it's super sweet it's
a little creepy to me it's like [ __ ]
a dead body though
but he'd rather [ __ ] a dead body than
another woman that's sweet that is sweet
if something happened to nikki i'm just
trying to picture i think i don't think
i could handle having photos around me
for a while yes
i would just be yeah yeah i would have
to
like that movie with [ __ ] um um
what's his name
mr uh jim carrey or something where he
goes into the brain
beautiful mind spotless mind i'll get
your brain erased
yeah um eternal sunshine and spotless
mind
yeah yeah hey you didn't know i know
because you guys could throw me off but
yeah
like that it would be tight is there a
movie called a beautiful mind
there it is yeah it was a math one
russell chrome oh
never mind well yeah i think that it's
it's so weird cause um i know this
feeling
because when my pet bird died
me and my mom we had a burial for it and
i was thinking about that [ __ ]
all day
and after school i ran home i unburied
that [ __ ]
i put him in a plastic bag and i put him
back in the grave
because i said that when jesus comes
he's gonna resurrect all of us and so
that [ __ ] needs to have his body
if the worms eat it he's not going to
have his body oh that's so thoughtful
yeah
so i was like the rapture come already
[ __ ]
and then the rapture comes and he's in a
plastic bag and he's like suffocating
i was like in second or third grade but
my friend uh he caught that
he caught this sparrow because you know
like on the street signs if you shake it
they'll be nests and the sparrows will
fall out
so he would grab him and then he would
sell sparrows for a dollar
wow they're [ __ ] so cute that's so
fun yeah
dude he would catch lizards and all this
stuff and he had a whole like
animal store what is he doing now i
don't know i haven't talked to him in
like
20 years i thought to have a [ __ ] pet
shop at my house because nikki
wants to start doing kitten rescue [ __ ]
we're gonna like foster kittens no you
know they never leave right i know man
we're gonna have nine cats right now you
just fall in love with them and you
can't let them go
and then people don't they don't they
don't buy them like hotcakes like they
don't take them
right yeah like it's gonna take more
cats
that are like yeah there's no way i
could foster animals i'm just gonna
fall in love with them and then i've
been to people that foster animals
and the minute you go there you can tell
they're judging you like oh so you're
gonna be that yeah
i'm like i don't think he'll be a good
attitude good puppy mm-hmm you know i'm
just keeping all of them
mm-hmm we've just been going to this
place for so long this kitten rescue
organization that we finally want to
actually do something so i'm like
[ __ ] man i'm gonna love every single one
of these little [ __ ] i'll do a
uh i'll do a three-day airbnb so like
they're like oh yeah the dog needs a
couch surf he could stay with me
for three days max on the second day i
don't know if it works like that
i know but then i'm making up my own
rules oh i see like it's like oh
he needs a crash all right he could stay
i have an extra room
i couldn't do it and it's like you gotta
leave now dawg
[ __ ] you you gotta go
that way that way that's what happened
to us when we lost our one of our dogs
and we were going to every shelter to
find her
we didn't find her but we ended up
coming home with another
oh yeah so we got meatloaf that's so fun
so we definitely can't foster that
i saw meatloaf yeah i was like we didn't
even get her back each other in the eyes
and they're like you're coming home with
us is that how it was like what was that
for you
honestly so before that i had another
german sherpa named tyson and he's been
with me for 15 years
so i was missing that dude and then when
we're looking for
briggy at the animal shelter we're just
going up and down the rows
and then i saw a dog that kind of looked
like tyson i'm like oh look at this guy
and everyone's trying to
like get him to come to the front of the
gate but he's all sad so he's sitting in
the back
and then i went to the gate and i'm like
hello and he walks up to me
so we have like a connection and then
i'm like don't you dare look me in the
eyes
and he did and i looked him back in the
eyes and then i'm like
um can you open this game so they opened
the gate and i went to go play with them
he's super friendly
and then we brought fawn in the front we
know he was a [ __ ] murderer
and the fawn got along with him really
good so we end up bringing him home
heart of gold this guy and he roasted
his ass that's all he was waiting for
the whole time
i thought this was super sweet i started
thinking i'm like i don't know if i
would want
if i would want how far would you guys
go it's not even up to you
anymore so like you know how some people
have uh a lot of asian homes have
shrines
like they have that little altar and
they have pictures of their grandparents
or
whoever right yeah i didn't grow up with
that
so for me i believe always in moving on
and then
you had a period in time where you kind
of like had
a time with that person and you go okay
that was cool and then
they're just in my memory and then i'll
have like old photos but i don't have
like a thing where
um a lot of people every day they'll
have a ritual where they like yeah get
some fruits light some incense and then
they'll be like hi dad or whatever like
pay some respects or whatever yeah
and then or they would visit frequently
to the graveyard like on their birthday
or whatever
i never did that with my family um i
haven't done that either
yeah i did that with my family but in
our house we don't really have a shrine
but we do have a pictures of pictures of
all the family but i don't do the daily
ritual stuff
i went to the graveyard with you and
your dad one time too i forgot why
where all you do is just bow and then
you bounce it takes you longer to get
there than the time you spend there
probably yeah but i forgot why i was
there with them my dad
is the most heartless sentimental man in
the world
so my dad like uh we he's just practical
he's very practical so my
my and also i have something to compare
to because my my dad's dad my grandpa he
passed away
so for every big event like my birthday
tyco's birthday anyone's birthday his
birthday
we always go there and pay respects my
mom because she's extreme buddhist her
version of paying respects is having
like an hour ceremony where you're on
your knees and you're like a full month
and you're chanting and doing all this
stuff
my dad we literally like spend maybe an
hour on the phone talking about when
we're gonna meet and all that we finally
go we go pick them up
we go there and then we go we see my
grandpa's
grave and he just bows once and goes
what do you want to eat
and then maybe that's why i don't
remember because it was so fast oh yeah
he sticks to it
how often does he go every big
like when i graduated college like all
of those things any big event
he's like let's go share it with your
grandpa which is pretty cool because
there's people out there
who have a canopy yeah they have benches
they're like
drinking having like little lunch and
picnic next to
some you know grandma or whatever and
i'm like damn that is
uh something that didn't exist in my
family yeah like after we got married my
gran my dad would be like oh let's go
tell your grandpa
uh you got married and then we'll all
cool so we go there we just balance and
go go eat something
when i was like six years old my dad
took us to where my grandpa
uh is his dad and you know we just stood
there whatever
and then we're driving back and i was
just having an honest kid question where
i was like hey do you think that he he's
like a skeleton
now oh [ __ ] and my dad was like what the
[ __ ]
basically like and i didn't know that
that was like wrong like i just was
genuinely curious if he's a skeleton now
yeah
how old are you i was sick that's a
normal [ __ ] question yeah but that's
what i mean like we're oh i was really
sensitive yeah yeah yeah was he just
astonished or was he mad
he was like astonished and then man you
[ __ ]
idiot yeah they gotta want to picture my
dad like that no
i'm wondering if he's a skeleton
[Music]
you